whoo
it's all hot i don't think
the crap teams of football are going to
be in this conversation either one i
don't think desean watson is going to go
like oh yeah i'll go to the jets
so
hot well uh he does want to go to the
jets that was the report that came from
armando salguero over the weekend of the
miami herald that the first choice right
now for deshaun watson is the new york
jets because of the presence
of robert sala as the head coach the
same robert sala that watson recommended
the texans interview and they completely
ignored him the only team that had a
head coaching vacancy in this cycle that
didn't interview robert sala
was the houston texan right so choice
one jets
despite our opinions of a week ago that
doesn't mean the jets want them and we
haven't heard that yet we just heard
sean maybe that favors them but but you
know what he's playing it well because
jets won dolphins two so hey jets if you
don't want me i'll just go to another
team in your division and maybe number
three is the patriots who knows but uh
look this is not getting any better mort
reported over the weekend that watson
wants out regardless of who they hire to
be their head coach there's a sense
they're trying to hire someone yeah who
will placate desean watson
the report from the weekend was it
doesn't matter now here's the thing i'm
waiting for and we haven't heard it yet
and i mentioned this last week on our
our pre-game show before the ravens
bill's playoff game i've written about
it a couple of times he's yet to say the
magic words he's yet to say trade me he
knows that once he says trade me there's
no turning back so
ipso facto whatever that means it sounds
good it's latin i think
he he hasn't crossed the bridge yet
right he's on he's on it
right he's halfway close to the other
side yeah he's halfway
but he still can turn around and until
he says trade me if he isn't saying
trade me because he knows that's a point
of no return that means he's not past
the point of no return yet yeah well
yeah yes agreed i mean he has to kind of
hedge his bet a little that way right
but we know at the same time
people representing him and everything
like that and maybe even the houston
texans at this point now they're
starting to call and get a feel so he's
going to have a feel
of what's there to be had or not to be
had before he ever has to even make that
statement right i mean at least that's
the way it seems to me um so
i'm sure they're doing their due
diligence until that point till they
absolutely have to
obviously the guy had a a a liking to
robert sala i get it listen i mean you
know he was out there the 49ers you got
great energy you could say what you want
you know it it shows he's
there he's easy to want to play for
definitely
what i just question with the jets and
dolphins thing or just the jets things
in general
i just want to go you know listen it's
new york it's the jets there is nowhere
to go but up i understand that
everything about that cool but man
like come to the jets and like what
trade away the first and second round
pick for the next two years and lose but
they have two i know two i know but they
need a lot i mean they were you know up
there is the worst team in football
until the last three weeks that's that's
where i just i don't know if i would
love that if i'm watson
but but let's let's think about it yeah
what would you have tried
let me try something here and uh
uh this this wasn't planned so i don't
know how it's gonna go let me ask you
this would you
trade straight up the second overall
pick for deshaun watson would you do
that if you were the jet
probably yes i would
would you if you were the jets if the
texan said that's not good enough if you
were the jets and you still had jamal
adams on the roster and you know
everything there is to know about jamal
adams and what he wants and you know
he's not happy he's depressed because
you're losing all the stuff we've heard
all year if jamal adams hadn't been
traded yet would you trade the second
overall pick plus jamal adams to get
deshaun watson uh well let's like you're
saying if i'm running knowing that he
wants out knowing everything they knew
last night apples to apples i would do
it if i was running the jets i don't
know if i would do any of this i i i'm
not but yes but i i hear my point is
this my point is this what they got for
jamal adams was two first-round picks so
if you think of it that way we're we're
using our second overall pick in the
draft to get to sean watson and we're
throwing in jamal adams a guy who didn't
want to be here anyway because we're
giving up the two first-round picks that
we got for jamal adams yeah look it
takes it takes some
suspension of disbelief it's gonna take
first-round picks though but that's how
you get there but that's how you justify
it i remember when i remember when the
vikings gave up
a lot to get jared allen from the chiefs
a one and a three
and it was explained to me at the time
well we look at it this way jared
allen's our first round pick we'll take
it and we're using a third round pick to
ensure that our first round pick is a
pretty damn good player so that that's
how
people need to quit thinking of draft
picks as lottery tickets and think about
them as players if you can
parlay the second overall pick in the
draft plus a guy who didn't want to be
there
anyway and you were going to have to
move into deshaun watson it's easier to
it's easier to justify it it is then to
say we're giving up three first-round
picks for the guy right but i mean
that's what just you know the current
market things we've seen over the last
few years right jaylen ramsey khalil
mack who else am i missing mike with big
time trades the ones that we've seen two
for jamal adams you just mentioned him
two first round picks i mean you've got
to think desean watson is getting
three first round picks this is a proven
commodity top five quarterback in
football end of conversation so three
first round picks and
then some maybe i would imagine and
that's where i that's where i start to
worry if i'm a team that's not really
that well built to begin with and needs
a bunch of offense alignment and we need
a running back and we need receivers and
we need a db and man we need middle
linebackers and oh my gosh we have no
pass rushers that's where i understand
watson wanted to come here but it's just
man that's it's not the greatest support
system couple of things
yeah number one right jets haven't had a
franchise quarterback since joe namath
right
and they haven't i mean sam darnold ken
o'brien was probably the closest thing
franchise quarterback i'm just saying
closest thing but go ahead yeah come on
right but not a franchise quarterback
they haven't had one since joe namath i
mean chad pennington you could say
for you know if you squint a little bit
maybe franchise quarterback but at times
but no but it was and brett favre for
you know like eight games right
they want a year in and year out answer
at the position that's what they want
that's why they traded up to get sam
darnold a few years ago and if and if
you're not sold on sam darnold that's a
threshold question what does robert sala
think about sam darnold right what does
woody johnson say now that he's back
let's not underestimate
the potential impact of woody johnson
being back and running the team again
but if you want that franchise guy
you've got the second overall pick if
you're thinking about using the second
overall pick on a quarterback wouldn't
you rather get somebody who has shown he
can do it because what if you draft
justin fields and he stinks sure you
don't know just because all these
younger guys have come in and played
well doesn't mean they're all going to
play well no i you're right you don't
know
at the base line
where
i like the jets and robert sala i like
deshawn watson i want to say to the jets
i feel like i've seen enough from sam
darnold to say you can make it work he's
good enough he needs a little help
you know he needs help that that's the
biggest thing and deshawn watson i'm a
you know i'm a huge fan just like you
are i want to tell him don't go there
they need to be
rebuilt and to get you
you're going to really hinder their
rebuilding process because they're going
to have to trade away a boatload of
assets to get you so that's where i just
i don't love it and i know we've made
that you know i i know you wrote an
article about it last week i believe and
we've talked about it you know if i'm
the jets a little bit i am thinking
about the ryan tannehill and the miami
dolphins in that situation you know
again yeah i know sam darnold hasn't
looked like the third pick of the draft
but they've done absolutely nothing to
support him all those other quarterbacks
that were drafted in that first round
minus josh rosen baker mayfield they
went all in on giving him talent i mean
all in they went all in josh allen we
saw last year they started to go all in
on him too lamar jackson yeah maybe not
receivers and things like that but
they've gone all in and formulating an
offense that fits him and making it work
for him sam darnold didn't get any of
that luxury and that's where i just
think it's an interesting conversation
but but still you bring in a guy who is
a proven i know oddity who can play the
quarterback position at a ridiculously
high level who can attract free agents
to town definitely what changes a
culture they're trying to change a
culture there with the new york jets and
robert sala helps change that culture
look i so you're in favor is what you're
saying that you're you're you think the
jets should make the play yeah look i i
mean
you're talking about the assets that
they're burning that could be devoted to
making the team better what the hell
have they done with the assets that
they've used that weren't traded away so
you know it's not all that hard and i
know that joe douglas the gm of the team
is trying to build from the inside out
right and you could argue you need
better linemen on both sides of the ball
before you address the quarterback
position but the quarterback position is
so critical at some point fans are going
to be back and that's one thing the jets
have struggled with since they opened
metlife stadium selling the tickets
selling the psls they haven't been able
to capture that magic and they're always
in competition with giants and their
fans and you get deshawn watson you've
got the best quarterback in town right
out of the gates yeah there's a huge gap
between him and daniel jones now daniel
jones has a ceiling he may or may not
get to but watson was patrick mahomes a
year before patrick mahomes right watson
was the guy who played as a rookie who
was awesome as a rookie before he tore
his acl right and i think has been
struggling in the shadow of patrick
mahomes because he doesn't have travis
kelsey he doesn't have tyreek hill he
doesn't have that offensive line he
doesn't have that defense and
and that's one of the reasons why
fundamentally i think watson wants out
he looks at mahomes he looks at josh
allen he looks at these other
quarterbacks and he says
i just want a little bit of what they've
got yeah i i agree i mean i i don't i
don't you know disagree in any any way
there i don't it hasn't been a great
defense in houston the last few years
you know they haven't been able to run
the ball we know we talked about pass
protection issues really the two to
three years before this season
it's been an uphill struggle
let alone
you know yeah they fired billy o'brien
who was his guy and of course was there
to draft him and the guy that kind of
tutored him and now it's like whoa what
the hell is going on in this
organization and i don't know where
we're going or what's being done and i
don't know some of these new people here
that are running it and he doesn't he
doesn't like it and i get it and i i
think if i'm sitting there and i'm him i
wouldn't want to be there either
yeah i mean you can sit and wait and
hope that maybe it's going to turn
around but through four seasons you've
probably seen enough to know
that that uh you know it's not going in
a good direction i've seen people say
well why did you take the contract and
well you know they're going to dangle
that money you're not going to say no to
it you deal with the financial
ramifications later if you decide you
want out but you're not going to say no
to generational wealth ever no
and of course not and
you know why would he take the contract
why because i mean i don't know it gives
them power it gives them it gives them
power to be the leader of the football
team the no trade cause everything like
that is going to all help him kind of
steer the ship the way he wants to steer
it as far as the trade conversation and
all those type of things so he wanted he
signed the contract with the
the best intentions i mean he didn't
sign the contract thinking like wow here
we go deshaun watson and then he wrote
ps underneath i'm going to screw you
guys in a year and a half
no he was much more sooner right or
sooner he went into this with thinking
like i want to build something and of
course it's all falling apart ever since
that moment really well and that's what
happened the gm slash head coach gets
fired jack easterby does the power play
the reports are out there they're
ramping about the way he's trying to
take over the team it's plunged into
dysfunction what a shock you put a
grossly unfit guy in charge of the team
and the team becomes dysfunctional who
would have ever guessed that something
like that would happen when someone
grossly unfit is in charge of anything
but i digress or i don't um but now he's
at a point where he's trying to figure
out what the hell is going to happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports